okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel today I'm
talking about how to quit drinking and
steps you can take before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification
Bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos Okay so
when I was in college
I was a binge Drinker let me tell you I
it was bad like I've really enjoyed
bonding with people over drinking like I
really liked having something in common
with people I really liked social
environments so I really enjoyed like
drinking is fun
um but what I realized was the more I
drank the worse I felt about myself so
for example
I gained like 15 pounds throughout
College
and I'm not like that and then I
realized I was relying on alcohol as a
crutch instead of just becoming a better
communicator and maybe working on my
anxiety and social situations like
instead of doing that I would just rely
on alcohol because
immediately when you drink like you have
something in common with people
but what I realized was long term it
just didn't make sense for my life
um I'm a very long-term thinker like I
always think about how things
will pan out 10 years from now and
logically like I've been drinking for
three years
and
I'd gained 15 pounds so if I kept doing
that I was just gonna get fatter and
fatter and fatter I can't be fat
I've been chubby oh my gosh I've been
chunky but I've never been to the point
where like the world looks at me as fat
and I I don't ever want to get there and
so
the way I thought about it was okay if
you're even if you're only having a
couple drinks a week like that adds up
throughout the year
on top of that I noticed my sleep
schedule wasn't very good like I didn't
get quality sleep when I drank and I
felt like if I drink on Saturday the
whole week I would just spend
making up
for that like lost sleep I don't I'm
sure there's a scientific reason but
anyways so
I did not quit drinking cold turkey it
was something that I took in a small
steps so I knew that I really crave a
social environment and half the reason I
drank was because I really liked that
environment and
at some point I knew that I was gonna
have to start taking myself
out of those situations but
I didn't I'm not someone that goes from
zero to 100 overnight I really have to
do like small incremental changes so
when I graduated college the first thing
I did was I would still go to the bars
and like those places that people drank
but I would surround myself with people
that maybe drank less and didn't go as
like hard
um and on top of that like I'd really
practice
control so I'd really practice like five
drinks or less four drinks or less but
whatever it was and then I started going
out to those same situations but I like
would just drink water and I'd bring
like a different type of drink and I
would just
I don't know build off of that so like
first I limited it to five drinks or
less did that for maybe six months then
I just started drinking like water and
what I realized when I drank water is
there's a weird phenomenon and I don't
know why this you're gonna think I'm
crazy but you start to feel drunk when
everyone else is drunk but you're not
like you start to get that giddy feeling
because everyone's Giddy and happy and
like in a good mood and if you just wait
if you just wait it out like whenever
you feel the most anxious like you want
to drink if you just give yourself an
hour you will start to feel drunk
because everyone around you is in this
mood
and it's similar to
if you walk into a room and 10 people
are depressed like you start to kind of
kind of
kills your mood it's the same thing when
you walk into your room and 10 people
are happy like you start to get happy
and like carefree and happy-go-lucky and
I don't have that same feeling almost
that you get when you're drunk
it doesn't make sense I don't I don't
know how but I started to realize that
and so then my mind was like
hey you don't even have to have the side
effects of drinking and you can still
feel drunk
um
so then okay then next
and this I think if you are very
addicted to drinking um and you've been
doing this for like five plus years I
think I was a little bit luckier because
I really didn't do it that long
but if if you have I would really really
recommend changing cities
and this is going to be the hardest part
because I know that's not in the cards
for everyone but this was like the most
instrumental
like the best thing I could have did for
myself I moved from Chicago to Milwaukee
because I knew that Milwaukee to Chicago
was an hour and a half drive and
I knew I wasn't going to want to make
that drive every weekend to hang out
with the same people that had been
drinking and like doing all this stuff
so I moved
and
yeah and I specifically picked friends
that didn't drink just so I could really
like reinvent my life so I got really
involved in a church there
um I ended up like living with a couple
girls from the church and I did Bible
study like twice a week
um which I mean not everyone's religious
so it could be
joining a sports team or you know some
other type of organization and people
that really aren't that into drinking
for me it was church
um
so that was this first thing I did and
the second thing is I asked myself what
hobbies do I need to develop to make
myself not want to drink so there has to
be something out there that I am going
to like more than drinking
and this this is outside of changing
your environment I think this is the
most important thing is to I really had
to ask myself why am I drinking like why
do I feel the need to rely on this and I
realize it's because I felt no purpose
in my life
um I my purpose for 22 years had always
been Sports I was the only thing I cared
about and when that was gone I was so
sad I had nothing
um so for me what I figured out that I
actually like is I really like politics
don't ask me to talk about that on this
channel um I really liked
religion like I'm very curious about you
know what happens after
music I love music I love to sing um I
learned to play guitar in this period
um
and YouTube and then I learned how to do
YouTube and Video Edit and I realized if
I
didn't partake in
in going out to bars and going to these
events like I would have time to become
the person that I wanted to be now
this is a little bit harder and this is
something I've been thinking you know on
and off about because I know as like
women we kind of have more of a pressure
and like you know a need if we want to
have kids to get married earlier and I
will say
this dead take away from my dating life
like I really did not date for like
um beers and I'm not even I know
um people will think
um like especially red pill people will
be like oh you were sleeping with
someone no no I just
there's like nothing for two years I
went on a couple dates off of dating
apps but it's like honestly I just
didn't have the time for it because I
was so consumed and like learning guitar
learning music learning YouTube really
trying out my sales job too that was
another thing
and
yeah so
and the last thing this is the last
thing you cannot have any leeway when
you say that you are not drinking if you
tell someone you are not drinking
tonight or I don't drink you cannot go
back on your word because those people
will not respect you and you
I I know they're gonna bug you about it
I know people are gonna Nag on you oh
come on you're being a boar whatever but
do that for 10 times and people will
leave you alone because people like they
want to save their energy and if you say
no enough times
they'll leave you alone and this was
hard for me because I'm a people pleaser
like I always wanna like do what my
friends want to do but
no you can't you can't do that you have
to be super firm and just say I'm not
drinking or I don't drink and the last
time when I moved to London that's what
I started saying I started saying I
don't drink and that was the best
results I've had like people really
don't push it
um
you really need to know yourself and
know if you can still go to these type
of environments
for me I had to remove myself for a
while before I could really
put myself back in situations where I
drank
um so for a couple years I really didn't
go to I don't want to say I never went
to a bar or party or anything like I
would go on maybe once every couple
months but it was nothing like I used to
so
yeah that's like my personal story how I
stopped drinking and how I would
recommend someone that doesn't want to
just do it overnight like cold turkey
would stop drinking but let me know in
the comments what you guys think I think
I told all the steps because
yeah the last thing you have to do is
just say I don't drink
and I promise you guys
so much good will come out of it
especially as a girl like guys give you
a different level of respect when you
don't drink like especially guys that
like want to be married and wanna
you know are looking for something more
long-term like they that they really
respect that so I don't know
um let me know in the comments what you
guys think don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
I will talk to you guys next time